les chiffres et on va passer tout de
suite à la boîte à poux cave et je crois
que soprano a même une pique à vannes
faire sur quelqu'un mais qui pour
l'instant la boîte à bukavu savez ce que
c'est vous l'attendez tous les soirs aux
alentours de 20h30 sont les chroniqueurs
qui vont dénoncer les choses sur les
chroniqueurs alors et même le public ou
même les gens de la production à
benjamin a fait une interview à europe 1
en ces temps hier dans le pantalon mais
non mais alors il nous en parlera plus
tard puisqu'il n'est pas là il est prêt
d'ailleurs il est prêt il fera son
passage dans un instant mathieu demande
à ses assistants d'envoyer des messages
de bonne année à ses contacts et oublie
l'anniversaire de ses assistants mais
non non c'est vrai ça rien à l'horaire
non mais non mais non c'est pas vrai ce
qui est vrai c'est que leur demande qui
me signifie des anniversaires comme ça
je peux les envoyer en disant gros bide
je vis un truc
isabelle a fait du badminton avec la
culotte marron un bon pastis me réjouis
commencé costis ma oui quand on est allé
au maître le jour où j'ai pris plein de
chocolat ouvriers oui c'était tellement
sexy chocolat que d'anglais dans les
vestiaires eh bien je me suis
déshabillée il ya une jeune femme car il
fait franchement c'est dégueulasse parce
que la culotte
tout était mal le pauvre christine kelly
était incontrôlable à la soirée
d'anniversaire d'eric mendes le
chauffeur de salle à
est-ce qu'on a des images paris allez-y
là
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'arriver
vous avez vu toi ta petite histoire on
dirait une meuf qui va voir une araignée
dans sa chambre mais ce serait ici où je
n'attendais là je viens de dire un autre
truc sur christine kelly christine kelly
a été vu en train de passer un bon
moment avec quelqu'un qui doit de
l'argent à cyril alors ça c'est une
trahison façon à quoi l'équipe qui doit
de l'argent avec qui vous étiez c'est
quelqu'un qui vous doit être 3 millions
mais et puis je sais pas comment vous
allez c'est rare quand vous étiez un
collier avec rabat avec le président du
csa aujourd'hui mais c'est la somme
présidera ça va j'ai eu peur c'est un
gars le soir juste après l'émission
quelli repasse dans les loges pour
embarquer des confiseries des canettes
qui fait d'elle oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai rien dit bac tout le
monde le voit donc cela dit ça on va
partir avec des sacoches
on sait bien qu'à pas un supermarché au
marsala on la voit tous les soirs en
train de partir avec des sacs mais on
sait bien que la page du barreau j'avais
une copine qui dormait chez moi ouais
c'est s'en est pas le temps de faire les
courses avait pas de vous nous
remboursera rsa
rémois sont à soudoyer le dj de tpb pour
passer la musique d'un de ses potes dans
l'émission non sauf que le dj n'a rien
compris et l'a passé pendant la pub qui
balança oui bah les gens qui sont mal
informés ouais des gens qui m'avaient
pas beaucoup de monde qui est vrai mais
je vous le dis mais c'est vraiment en
moi le populaire la femme de benjamin
castaldi est tellement jaloux ce qu'elle
a souvent appelé la production pour leur
demander de parler de ses ex de plus
parler à mon ami raymond a inventé une
maladie à son père pour ne pas prendre
une amende de stationnement non c'est
quoi cette histoire s'est pas quoi quoi
quoi qu'est-ce qui est oui mais non
c'est pas ça
vous dites moi puisque c'était mal
garées en fait les flics sont venus pour
me dire on va vous mettre il était en
train de leur bonne main et j'ai dit
j'étais obligé de me garer là parce que
mon papa du diabète et je peux pas me
garer ailleurs puisqu'il faut qu'ils
m'ont je les monte à l'étagé je m'en
vais tout de suite en paix mais ça je
sais qu'il a balancé par eco mais
c'était le désert c'était vrai ça c'est
loïc qui a balancé ça oui ah ouais c'est
lui qui avait lancé c'est loïc mon ami
louis gallois qui a balancé il a bien
fait doc a eu une aventure avec une star
de cinéma au rebond ah oui c'est vrai
genre on est potes vous avez eu une
aventure avec une star de cinéma se
souvient plus oui bah oui moi bah oui il
a vu il a vaincu écrite non dessous
c'est qu'il avait dénoué nom assez qui
banon ne sais pas comment c'est louis
plusieurs faits a eu une aventure avec
une star de cinéma en méditation télé on
sait les aventures artistiques à quoi
oui j'ai fait une chanson avec wii avec
qui une aventure sentimentale oui non
pas pas une aventure koh lanta connard
oui kabbani cta fecteau l'entamé du
match j'ai fait des diot
j'ai fait des poussées que lectrice
non non alors alors tu vas essayer de
retrouver de quoi il s'agit alors là je
sais pas une cadart je sais pas qui a
sorti à cyril est tellement passionné de
tennis qu'un jour il a utilisé une
raquette pour taper quelqu'un qui
voulait attaquer sa meuf face à un autre
face à un automobiliste
alors bien sûr c'est vrai tu le connais
trop statique ça sèmerait cette histoire
c'est le christ et wadi qaysiyya raconte
l'histoire et quoi l'histoire c'est pas
moi je le jure il existe vous êtes déjà
membre et qu'avec bracket de cette cvo
chine possible bon c'est possible
j'imagine tout cas qui vient de tomber
la faya il ya une heure pendant
l'émission pendant c'est que de la télé
c'est quoi il ya une chroniqueuse qui
nous a avoué que vous étiez complètement
sa came et que vraiment llm et vos yeux
et votre petit tu as bossé de leur amour
une chroniqueuse on l'a dit on a les
images c'est moi c'est oui c'est un
délire
j'adore je pense que c'est votre délire
oui regardez ludivine est ce que vous
avez déjà fantasmer sur quelqu'un de
pouvoir qui est votre patron
éventuellement alors vous savez moi
c'est pas le pouvoir je vous jure le
pouvoir ça me fait rien du tout d'accord
mais il n'était pas mon patron à
l'époque mais j'avoue que je trouvais le
cyril hanouna vrai dès les années 2000
se trouvait ultra ça vous êtes en train
de nous dire les pakistanais qui est
nôtre pas producteur de cette émulation
du mans était votre came
mais il était ma came à l'époque où il
montré ses fesses tout le temps sur
comédie en même temps voyez nuit par
contre il faisait exprès de susciter le
désir on a d'accords préexistants et
nice
allons un peu mais celle-ci ne pas
allons un peu plus avant mais en fait de
votre repas dès maintenant que c'est
votre
est ce que justement le fait que ce soit
votre patron maintenant ce serait un
fragment
ben oui à jamais à non je pourrais pas
bon non faudrait qui me renvoie un
bateau a pas que moi
d'accord et sinon qu on y est maintenant
à 20h36 je suis en mesure de vous le
dire
ludivine tué direct
[Applaudissements]